[Música]
será que eu sou um coitadinho
ou será que eu sou um super herói pra
responder essa pergunta eu vou contar
pra vocês
a história de um colega meu chamado pelo
site de contar a história do pedro tem
pra vocês que se tem uma vantagem ser
cego é você não vê o tempo que falta
você falar sobre tudo mas voltando ao
pedro
o pedro é um amigo meu cego e ele foi
contratado para trabalhar numa empresa
quando ele chegou nessa empresa
os outros colaboradores os outros
funcionários achar o máximo para que
bacana como a nossa empresa cuida do
social empresa que que sabe né tá super
alinhado com essa questão da
responsabilidade pessoal achou muito
legal essa história da empresa contratar
um rapaz sério funcionário chegava em
casa e contavam com todo orgulho do seu
esposo para a sua marida o meu amor se
não sabem empresa que trabalha demais
mesmo contrato rapaz ceguinho lameu
presa boa esta é que o trabalho é meu
bem ma que ele faz
não sei direito mas ele está lá em evitá
la é muito legal ver o cara 100 mil para
cego namoro era cego falar assim mas e
ele com o nome dele nem acho que não
perguntei num no almoço se encontra é
que às vezes sinto meio longe o tempo
passou a limpeza na empresa dom pedro
até que teve um dia final de ano o
pessoal começou a organizar uns o
rascunho para comemorar esses de
confraternização no final de ano
o pessoal começou a organizar todo mundo
empolgado porque era no sítio de um
diretor um sítio muito bacana o pessoal
já tinha ido algumas pessoas da empresa
o pessoal empolgado comentando caramba
isso é muito legal né e até que alguém
lembrou pedro chamou pedro bom pedro não
chamar apesar que para ele não sei se é
muito legal né
vou ver o que tem bacana lá no sítio
para fazer bom é aquela cachoeira que é
muito legal aquela cachoeira tem um
monte de pedra com limão imagina a gente
leva o pedro na melhor das intenções ele
escorrega também quer fazer uma boa ação
pode ver uma tragédia é jogar futebol
pedro vai jogar futebol também olhar
mulherada da firma né
ali na piscina desculpa eu gente mas os
homens passam esses comentários
grosseiros
é ele também não vai poder ver né até
que alguém pensou assim bom mas vamos
pensar no chão ele sim porque ele fica
na beira da piscina molhando o pezinho
na água leva uma carne melhor do que
ficar em casa ouvindo rádio não ter nada
para fazer lá falar com pedro
pedro vai ter churrasco aí é é no final
de semana vamos com a gente sabia ele é
o pedro falou neto sabendo mas pena que
neste fim de semana não posso de alguém
já pensou josé fabiana programa nada a
ver com o tema porque pedro que não pode
mais ser tão legal você fica sentado na
piscina estava a caminho de falar assim
não é que bem nesse fim de semana eu
tenho uma competição e pessoa pedro mas
como funciona isso corrida de aventura
começa vai lá e faz parte da equipe mas
como quero
a turma que vai correr passa por você
fala estou passando pelo fla vai forças
e faz parte da torcida quando o que é
mas o pedro explica não é eu faço eu sou
atleta da equipe
e daí o pedro começa a contar que ele
vai na academia todo dia que ele faz
bike naquelas também né a bicicleta para
duas pessoas que ele vai naquele
barquinho chamado do que aprendi a remar
que ele desce o rapel de 50 metros e
quando ele conta isso claro que vários
personagens só deve ser cego que ele não
sabe né
[Música]
como seu carro além de cega não tivesse
nos anos 50 metros é muito na idéia
perigoso mas o pessoal começa a achar o
máximo
ando pedro são pedro continua contando a
história mas para sabe que dessa vez é
um total empolgado também para essa
corrida mas porque pedro animal deve ser
muito legal
não é que a minha esposa não vai poder
ir comigo cara pensa ali atuam esposa
caso quem será que ainda mais que
descobrem que ela não tem deficiência
quem foi maluca que será que casa com
cara cego porque ela não vai poder ir
pedro porque lá a gente tem uma filhinha
de dois meses daí ela não vai ter que
ficar com a nossa filhinha caramba lente
casado ele transita tem filho e esse dia
todo mundo saiu da empresa o novo herói
pessoal chegou em casa aquele rapaz já
chegou com a esposa e precisa conhecer o
pedrão pedrão quem é pedro eo pedrão faz
rafting rapel ele meu daquele qual é
todo dia que era tudo bem mas quem é o
pedro você nunca me contou
claro que é meu o pedro pedro n modo de
ver eu vou trazer meu aniversário o cara
tem até filho mas quem é o pedro ken é o
seguinte fernando josé sá o ceguinho
virou pedro virou pedrão
o cara que era visto como um coitadinho
agora um super herói na empresa
mas o tempo passa o tempo passa e um dia
o chefe de um dos funcionários falou
assim profuncionário renato a gente vai
ter uma reunião muito importante na
sexta feira
e você é o responsável pelo relatório
vai ser baseado no seu relatório que a
gente vai discutir os temas da reunião
então favor caprichem no relatório e
renato se prepara manda um email pra
todo mundo que ele precisava mandar
pedindo as informações necessárias ali
pro relatório e o pedro era uma das
pessoas que ele mandou e mail enfim
chegou lá na reunião sexta-feira o
renato começa a apresentar depois de
algum tempo que estava apresentando o
chefe dele e faziam renato acho que eu
tinha deixado
claro o quanto importante era o seu
relatório completo porque eu tô vendo
que o relatório está incompleto faltando
informação é como quem vai fazer uma
discussão aqui de qualidade e daí o
renato falou eu sei que está faltando
mas é que as informações que eu pedi por
pedro não chegaram e o pedro estava na
reunião e fossem como assim não fosse
não me pediu nada senão pedir te mandei
meio nós enfim essa hora o renato ficou
bravo e ficou com raiva do pedro
depois eles descobriram que o e mail foi
preencher eletrônica enfim ou voltou ele
se entender
passou mais um tempo um dia estava
renato pedro no bar mundo comentando
sobre a vida
outro dia estava ali se abraçando quando
o brasil fez gol
o dia estava chorando junto com o brasil
foi desclassificado
o tempo mostrou que o renato e produz
funcionários dessa empresa que o pedro
não era aquele coitadinho que eles
imaginavam no começo e normalmente é
isso que a gente pensa na da pessoa com
deficiência
essas são as nossas primeiras impressões
o que ela não pode fazer a dificuldade é
tão difícil imaginar que a gente tente e
tenente não consegue nem se aproximar
muitas vezes a gente evita o contato com
medo de errar enfim mas depois como a
gente espera um pouco dessa pessoa tudo
que vem surpreende surpreende muita
gente começa a achar um super herói e o
tempo faz esse pêndulo equilibrar o
tempo nos mostra que uma pessoa com
deficiência pode sim né é ser uma pessoa
útil ou não para uma vaga ela pode ou
não se há de ser agradável com a
situação social como qualquer outra
pessoa que ela tem uma característica
importante que a gente não pode negar
que é a deficiência mas que é muito mais
do que isso para continuar essa conversa
do pedro
eu vou contar pra vocês três coisas a
gente fechar essa conversa
a primeira que tinham coloquei o nome de
pedro nesse personagem só para facilitar
a minha narrativa mas o nome desse
personagem é guilherme
a segunda coisa
sobre respeitar é esses funcionários
tiveram sim a oportunidade de viver todo
esse tempo né tiver um tempo pra fazer
esse pêndulo equilibrar mas muitas vezes
a gente não vai ter esse tempo a gente
não vai ter a oportunidade de conviver
a minha filha que tem sete anos ela está
acostumada a conviver com uma pessoa
cega que desde que ela nasceu o pai dela
é sério
só que por mais que eu queira que a
gente queira ninguém aqui vai ter
condição de conviver com todas as
possibilidades humanas relação né
as pessoas são únicas o nosso desafio é
esse
é fácil a gente respeitar aquilo que a
gente conhece aquilo que a gente
concorda o nosso desafio é respeitar
aquilo que a gente não conhece aquilo
que a gente não concorda eu gosto de dar
o exemplo por exemplo indo para um tema
que eu trabalho bastante nas empresas
que o tema lgbt
às vezes a gente fala de pessoas trans
algum sinal mas pra mim pessoa sttrans
essa coisa de pessoas trans não entra na
minha cabeça
como assim era homem ou mulher isso pra
mim não precisa entender aliás não está
nem concordar só respeita esse é o ponto
de partida para uma relação de qualidade
e o terceiro tema que eu quero falar com
vocês a terceira coisa pra fechar essa
conversa sobre incluir a gente só inclui
alguém de fato quando a gente consegue
ter por ela todos os sentimentos da
raiva a paixão
quando a gente se sente à vontade para
ficar bravo com ela quando ele se sente
à vontade para sorrir para dividir mas
sobretudo quando a gente se sente à
vontade pra errar
hoje em dia eu percebo nessa conversa da
diversidade que as pessoas têm muita
dificuldade às vezes com esse tema ou se
aproximar desses temas com medo de errar
porque toda hora que se abre à internet
que você vê uma palestra é a pessoa fala
'você tá sendo errado se está usando o
termo errado se está agindo errado isso
é aquilo se a smo não sei do que enfim
as pessoas acabam se afastando
e também por causa dessa experiência
nessa conversa da diversidade eu quero
dizer para vocês que eu conheço muitos
militantes por exemplo no tema lgbt que
coloca um monte de situações regras e
esses mesmos militantes têm enormes
dificuldades na hora que eles se deparam
com uma pessoa cega ou com a pessoa na
cadeira de rodas
eles não sabem nem cumprimentar assim
como eu conheço pessoas cegas também
super militantes que gostam de dita
regras que fazem piadas homofóbicas o
tempo inteiro mulheres feministas
empoderadas que tem uma dificuldade
enorme com a questão racial assim como
eu conheço militantes dessa questão da
eqüidade racial que fazem piadas
machistas
vira e mexe o que eu quero dizer com
isso gente é que nessa conversa do
respeito da inclusão todos nós somos
heróis e vilões e é só a gente se
desarmando a gente ficando à vontade com
esses temas ficando à vontade pra errar
que a gente passa a ter uma relação de
igual para igual
a gente não precisa de um coitado para
chamar de nosso
o que a gente precisa é e entender que a
outra pessoa tá de igual para igual e só
quer respeito nem eu nem ninguém que é
igual ao da garantia de igualdade no
ponto de chegada o que eu quero é o
respeito pelas minhas singularidades ao
longo do caminho porque daí eu chego
onde eu posso chegar e é só quando a
gente percebe né é a pessoa nem
coitadinha em super herói que a gente
fique à vontade pra e rápido a gente não
era com o coitadinho quente tem dó ea
gente num não arrisca errar com um super
herói que a gente vê nessa pessoa
então gente pra fechar eu queria
concluir e responder àquela pergunta que
eu fiz lá no começo eu não sou nenhum
coitadinho
nem o super herói eu sou o guilherme
muito obrigado